so
now you're dating and you're
in this world you're going on tour with
him and
was there a first step of like
oh this doesn't feel right it's
literally the first day on tour
the first day uh after the first concert
i looked around at the world cuz you
know
i guess i was like i was a
young teenage girl who idolized the
music industry and heard that tour was
this like magical thing and i was gonna
go on this bus ride into like
fantasyland and then like the first
night i i
it just hit me like a ton of bricks that
this was not what i thought it was gonna
be at all and i got
scared almost right away that i was in
way over my head but at that point i'd
taken so much media abuse and i had i
had put myself on the line to be in this
relationship with this person in this
very controversial way because i thought
i was in love
and then when i started to see it sort
of crumble and when he started hurting
me and when
it wasn't what i thought it was going to
be i was really
in such denial and in too much shame to
admit to myself that
maybe i'd gone down the wrong path you
know so there's a great uh tactic that
that
people like him use which is called
triangulation and yeah he did it with
with girls that that came after me and
so on and so on we realized you know
that there was a real pattern to to how
he sets up new relationships and what he
does and he really paints the the one
he's with as as this kind of crazy
abusive person and you're his friend and
he's like yeah man i'm going through all
this terrible stuff with this person i'm
with and they're really awful and they
make me feel terrible and they you know
he he made it sound like he was in an
abusive relationship you know and i'm
going oh my god which is gas lighting
gaslighting yeah poor baby he did the
same thing uh he said the same things
about me to to the girls that came after
me you know this is this is what he does
you know i have to paint this one is
crazy so that if she ever comes to you
and says
tries to warn you about the behavior
it's already set up that she's crazy so
you're
and and this went on for years the the
heart-shaped glasses video i think
really kind of put the pieces of the
puzzle together of how much
working in an industry
where you are required to
bear your soul say yes do what is asked
of you
right
so when you are with your lover and
you're making a music video
and you're stimulating sex
you know
where do you draw that line because it's
so confusing i knew
that i was uncomfortable that something
terrible was happening
uh but it was that oh god if if i say
anything i'm gonna get in trouble it's
gonna hurt me it's gonna hurt my career
i can never tell anybody that this
happened um and again just denial denial
push it down push it down and uh you
know the hardship glasses there's no
nudity contract that was drawn up there
was no you know normally when you do an
explicit sex scene it's it's talked
about before and this is what we're
going to do this is what we're going to
show this is what we're going to agree
to the footage will be destroyed
afterwards you sign a contract you know
that just didn't exist because this
wasn't the plan
and it wasn't until the cameras were
rolling that my clothes started being
pulled off of me but i do remember that
that day
when things started happening
very specifically having the thought
wait this isn't a dream
this is really happening like i felt
like i was in this dream like state i
was so out of it
um and it really wasn't yeah i was in
such shock when things were happening
was that also why you stayed with him
for years because sometimes people look
and go well if it was bad
why didn't you leave and get out
yeah that's the main question we always
ask uh uh people in in domestic violence
situations
um and i keep telling people you know
the fact that we're still asking that
question makes me
realize just how much work there is to
do and how severely misunderstood
this issue is and the psychology behind
it and how calculated
people like him are and how well-versed
they are in this type of manipulation
[Music]